[Musique]
en direct de montréal 20 septembre 2010
9,7 en termes canada une bonne partie
des employés de radio-canada
international sont si beaux pensions
quand on n'est pas nombreux
quoi c'est un dixième à peu près qu'il
est présent ici un studio et plus je
pense
alors on les présente de back gauche à
droite ou de votre droite à votre gauche
nous avons vraiment de marteau bonjour
aimant bonjour stéphane bonjour à tous
et puis aussi madame marie-claude ce
market avec nous on joue un bon jour et
j'ai sauté le meilleur pour la fin
jette aux couleurs du parti libéral du
canada
c'est un mois j'ai fait le lien entre
madame qui a dit noir et du rouge
vous qui avez le rouge vin est lui qui
est un noir c'est vrai moi j'ai mis les
deux cd couleurs d'automne tf1 puis 8 au
mois de novembre
j'ai bien compris c'est là le bois des
mois de démarches à l'aise mois des
noirs mais c'est pas tout à fait ça
c'est le matin c'est février le mois de
l'histoire des noirs voilà alors vous
n'avez aucune idée du sujet de
l'émission aujourd'hui non comme
d'habitude mais je vous présente des
images ne sautez pas aux conclusions
parce que vous allez vous trompez vous
allez par vraiment mal paraître la
lanterne
ça serait pas la première fois et non
pas la dernière vidéo 5 images tout le
monde à la maison au bureau et en avion
en cela rend notre premier ministre avec
un chapeau de cabrer
ouais avec un b ddpp un autre bébé
l'image numéro 3 maintenant mais c'est
vrai que là on parle de politiciens avec
des bidaouis on à l'ars sera l'heure des
fins politiciennes et politiciens avec
les bébés ben oui vous auriez pu vous
arrêter à l'image des politiques dans la
présente campagne électorale et on se
pose la question finalement est ce que
dans le fin fond des choses en ce moment
on a une campagne électorale à l'image
des canadiens et quatre ports d'image
évidemment ça fait sourire un petit peu
parce que tout le monde est où ta
planète au courant depuis mercredi soir
physiquement c'est vraiment ça explose
dans les médias il devait jouer dit les
humoristes américains s'amuse beaucoup
pour une fois c'est pas eux qui sont une
chose alors qui veut de raconter ce qui
se passe depuis 48 heures presque 48
heures au canada qui marie avec loeb
alors être des images du passé de notre
premier ministre ont été diffusées dans
les médias
premièrement dans le time magazine voit
donc c'est une image datant de 2001 on
le voit déguisés en personnages du conte
des mille et une nuits des contes des
mille et une nuits donc d'aladin c'est à
dire c'est une photo noir et blanc mais
on remarque très bien que sa peau et
maquillée foncez donc l'immédiat faisait
référence à branne fisc en fait qui fait
référence aux blacks fils mais on
parlait à ce moment-là de bronze fayçal
historiquement ce qui est très très
américain comme façon de faire c'est que
le black c'est toute une carrière comme
chanteur rob la crise ou si un
maquillait la personne
leblanc n'exagérait l'élève retour des
yeux et on jouait sur scène dès
carrément d'aidé ont poussé à l'extrême
des particularités du mouvement du geste
ou d'élocution et aussi se trouve
souventes fois c'était des on
représentait des gens mais de moindre
été ni épices les caricatures c'est ça
mon des préjugés sur sa part tout comme
le mexicain qui dort en dessous de garde
avec son sourire où ils se seraient
partis on a on est à une autre époque
maintenant pour rappeler que les
événements ces photos ont été captés il
ya 19 ans 20 ans alors qu'il était
essentiellement professeur d'art
dramatique
l'actuel de justin trudeau qui dirige
pour le moment ce président propos le
président sortant et ses ministres à sa
famille au milieu voilà que tu as fait
parce que j'ai trouvé intéressant parce
que j'ai suivi un petit à controverse
et là que ça vienne des états unis que
ça soit le commentaire très bon de dany
laferrière qui est un écrivain québécois
d'origine haïtienne qui fait partie de
l'académie française qui a dit c'est
intéressant qu'on a même d'abord qu on
s'offusque est que se déguise dans un
personnage de la dengue qui en fait fait
partie de la littérature et c'est une
fiction donc ne pas confondre sur
monsieur l'intérieur qui disait pourquoi
est-ce que blain ne pourrait pas se
déguiser en noir parce qu'elle est noire
aussi qu'ils le font il rappelait aussi
qu'à une époque
lorsqu'on faisait le black fils on
imaginerait excepté des personnages
qu'on voulait effrayant et effrayé linda
son vocabulaire à lui il disait
pour lui ce n'est pas problématique ne
s'est pas du blackface et d'ailleurs il
ya la ligue des noirs de montréal qui a
corroboré sa position à 8 alors
dépendant d'où l'on vient et qu'elles
sont le contexte dans lequel on a été
élevé on a une compréhension différente
de certains signes ou de ce que ça
valait semblerait que les francophones
au canada les anglophones de départ des
points de vue a plutôt partagés là
dessus un peu différent on va voir ça
avec notre invité dans un instant mais
pour le moment on avait prévu de toute
façon que le thème de cette émission
porte sur des élections canadien de
l'image des politiciens donc c'est
arrivé comme un cheveu sur la soupe ou
une pellicule sur le sol sur la soupe
sur le prix des légumes sans réponse
alors avoir écouté voici notre premier
jeu de l'émission y en a trois à chaque
émission des bulls à perdre 100 au total
on commence
petitement avec 20 boules seulement à
berne pour cette première question
représente la première question à
l'écran voyez savard on va tous
apprendre quelque chose aujourd'hui
voici la question
quels sont les expatriés canadiens qui
pourront également voter de l'étranger
le 21 octobre prochain lors de
l'élection générale
est-ce que c'est à ceux qui ont quitté
le canada depuis neuf ans ou moins
est ce que ces bébés seulement ceux qui
ont quitté le canada depuis cinq ans au
moins ou est ce que c'est
c'est ce qu'ils ont quitté le canada
depuis quatre ans au moins ou encore
j'adore ça toujours aucune de ces
réponses
la fameuse aucune de ces raisons du
drame
moi je vais prendre d aucune de ces
réponses sans explication c'est tout
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous expliquer
pas fait parce que ce récit pour
l'assécher viens moi je me range avec la
dame
ok ça fait beaucoup ça fait très lourd
là d'un côté trois et vous troisième
auxquelles des réponses on affiche n'a
pas de réponse
quelle est la bonne réponse ça s'en
viennent voiture kata kata en étant
passé une publicité là c'est sûr que
c'est la technologie
je vous le dis aux classes voilà bravo
detroit sa façon garden où au bout les
trois toute l'émission c'est ya quatre
ans il ya seuls les canadiens qui vivent
à l'extérieur du pays depuis moins de
cinq ans pouvaient voter mais la loi a
changé mais ça ils peuvent tous voté
alors écoutez je trouve ça assez
extraordinaire mais il y a seulement 19
b moins de 20000 exprès expatriés qui
sont inscrits sur la liste de pauvreté
sont à bruno broucqsault on estime qu'il
ya un million canadiens à l'étranger
manquait beaucoup qu'il ya des termes
comme par exemple les gens avec double
passeport
bien sûr d'accord alors voilà pour les
explications maintenant moi je suis je
pas le scientifique le spécialiste de
cette émission pour cela ils font fait
appel assurément qui scanne aise en
politique notamment aujourd'hui
geneviève tellier de l'école d'études
politiques à l'université d'ottawa était
expert en comportement électoral entre
autres choses
1 elle va nous parler le problème du
comportement de justin plutôt madame
tellier bonjour bonjour alors écoutez a
reparlé des grandes tendances au niveau
du vote de ce que les canadiens exprime
en ce moment le lors de sa campagne
électorale qui n'a que huit ou neuf
jours je pense qu est ce que vous pensez
de cette affaire d
des pellicules des photographies quel
genre et pas que ça à long terme c'est à
dire d'ici le 21 qu'est-ce que ça qu'est
ce que ça vient brouiller une analogie
sportive si on dirait que c'est un beau
diable convient de donner à justin
trudeau alors c'est une histoire
embêtante
c'est ce qu'aucun policier vue voix ou
vont être confrontés et ça vient peut
poser la question de la crédibilité de
monsieur trudeau c'est surtout ça le
problème c'est que monsieur trudeau
s'est fait le défenseur du
multiculturalisme et parent croisade
contre le racisme d'homophobie
le succès ces gens passent et il se fait
prendre un peu au détour ou enfin c'est
la première impression qu'on honore avec
cette histoire de blackburn face comme
ça qu'on l'a appelée ici et donc les
gens disaient ce qu'on plus est ce que
monsieur trudeau et sincère c'est cela
la question de fond c'est ce qu'on
cherche à savoir pendant une campagne
électorale on veut savoir c'est quoi les
toffes des leaders on connaît un peu
mieux justin trudeau parce que ça fait 4
1 qui est au pouvoir mais il ya
peut-être encore d'autres choses à
apprendre et c'est un peu de voir la
personnalité l'éthique la moralité la
façon dont il se comporte en situation
de crise ou si c'est tous ces aspects là
qu'on est en train de chercher avec
cette histoire là on le voit dans il ya
mercredi soir en avoir donnant ses
excuses aux canadiens pour à ne pas
avoir informé tout le monde de ce qui se
passait dans son passé est-ce que
jusqu'à maintenant il a la bonne
stratégie on s'excuse d'abord en
espérant que ça passe c'est vous vous
conseillez les politiciens des fois
l'occasion j'imagine avec votre grosse
tête
vous avez beaucoup d'informations alors
je peux apprendre à avoir la prétention
d'être une experte en relations
publiques il ya d'autres ils font mieux
que moi mais effectivement quand on
regarde un peu ce qui se passe chez les
politiciens la meilleure réponse dans un
code même c'est de répondre rapidement
puis vous le voyez dans l'avion en ce
moment alors en moins d'une heure quand
l'histoire est sorti monsieur mais ce
trudeau non seulement
avec une réponse à faire mais était
aussi prêt à répondre aux questions des
journalistes et sa tranche un peu avec
le mandat de monsieur trudeau ce à dire
que par le passé dans les dernières
années il ya eu d'autres crises qui ont
vraiment affecter sa crédibilité ou son
style de leadership et par le passé on
lui a reproché son manque de
communication de prendre son temps pour
attendre plusieurs jours avant de savoir
qu'est ce qui se passait et il semble
qu'on ait appris de ces crises l'
évidence que s'ils ont été très rapides
alors pour l'instant ce sera un faux pas
en termes de mode de gestion de crise ça
a été assez bien fait
est ce que ça peut devenir un problème
pour les autres leaders de mettre trop
l'accent là dessus aussi que par exemple
peut-être que monsieur ne veut pas
parler de pétrole ou d'oléoducs parce
que en ontario et au québec
c'est moins bien vu parce que là tous
les autres partis se sont mis un peu à
taper ce clou oui effectivement c'est
pas juste monsieur trudeau ce problème
là en bec tous les chefs de partis parce
qu'évidemment campagne tous les chefs de
partis veulent parler de leur plateforme
où se regarde les images d'introduction
de la bise prendre des bébés dans leurs
bras puis bon se montrer sur le meilleur
jour alors monsieur trudeau tôt que je
ne répondrai les autres chats soucis
sont obligé d'aborder cette question là
et il semble pour l'instant ce qu'on
entend c'est que la majorité des
canadiens pardonne le site rudeau alors
faut un peu aléatoire des choses en
disant oui cet ami inappropriée mais ça
s'est passé il ya très longtemps
de plus ces actions montrent ayant un
intérêt réel à aller vers le
multiculturalisme cette diversité se
défendre et défendre les groupes
minoritaires ou marginalisés et donc si
monsieur chiffres par exemple le chef du
parti conservateur tape trop sur le clou
en disant non et les racistes et les
racismes ça pourrait effectivement se
retourner contre lui parce que l'opinion
publique aurait de la difficulté à
suivre le raisonnement est elle d'accord
avec lui alors effectivement c'est un
terrain qui est assez glissant pour tout
le monde et tout le monde doit bien
évaluer sa stratégie commandez bond à
cette situation là moi je
je me demandais qu'est ce que vous
pensez du rôle et du comportement des
médias dans ce genre de situation là
parce que c'est vraiment eux qui mousse
ou non la sphère qui finalement ça
devienne un peu comme partisan d'un
parti c'est ici diffuse trop justement
là l'information comme le parti donne
qu'est ce que vous pensez de oui c'est
ça on peut se poser un peu la question
c'est toujours le phénomène de quand il
arrive un événement est prévu puis que
ça vient chercher les émotions on
commence à mettre beaucoup l'attention
sur ça on dirait qu'on veut presser
encore plus les politiciens pour aller
jusqu'au fond des choses pour voir
comment ils réagissent tout la pression
et on n'est plus dans les débats des
idées mais on est dans les modes d
impression du charisme mais tout ça est
donc est ce que c'est vraiment ce que
les gens ont besoin comme information en
campagne électorale
peut-être que jusqu'à un certain point
oui on veut savoir les toffes du leader
mais il faut pas aller trop poussé parce
qu'effectivement on risque de perdre
dans le jus principal qui celui d'être
en période électorale il hésite et puis
dans ce que c'est ce que moi j'ai trouvé
étonnant c'est que ça vient de médias
américain est donc la sensibilité des
médias américains est ce qu'elle est la
même que celle des centres des médias
canadiens
et là on voit que ça là une dimension
internationale est ici au canada on dira
pas regarder cnn on parle magazine au
gardien est ce que c'est important de
6-2 2-6 1-6 tant que ça à mon avis c'est
un enjeu canadien qui devrait être
discuté de façon canadienne d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien portant introduction qui
on vous avait dit à ses parents est-ce
que la campagne électorale est à l'image
des canadiens ben oui à devrait être à
l'image des canadiens blier et pour
relancer justement là-dessus
à l'image des canadiens ce qui est pas
une forme d' américanisation de la
politique ici notamment dans nos débats
débat qui s'en vient des chefs avec six
chefs
quand on regarde le quand on écoute les
débats américains où ça vole à une
bassesse épouvantables dans l'est dans
les propos c'est un peu là la bonhomie
canadienne disait ton qui est en train
de prendre le bord pour s'américaniser
je vais remplacer oui c'est un très bon
je remplacer le mot bonhomie par un
terme qu'on utilise plus nous autres qui
est le consensus canadien puis je pense
qu'il faut être conscient et il faut
être conscient
oui on est deux grands piliers vivant
côte à côte sur le même continent et on
a beaucoup de traits similaires mais il
ya une culture politique qui est très
différente entre les etats-unis et le
canada et aux états unis on est dans ce
qu'on appelle le pluralisme
c'est à dire les débats d'idées d'idées
contraire c'est à dire que on ne
construit pas qu'il peut y avoir
il peut y avoir une seule vérité mais il
ya différentes vérité qui sait qu'ils
valent et une des fois prévaut sur
l'autre alors autant la gauche que la
droite par exemple ont raison et on voit
vers l'alternance ce que ça amène comme
système sait qui on envoie vers une plus
grande polarisation c'était des gens qui
sont très campés sur leurs idées qui
veulent pas faire de concessions sachant
qu'un jour ils vont arriver au pouvoir
pour un certain temps puis après ça va
être un autre qui va être pouvoir
représentant une autre idée d'où le
principe de l'alternance
nous voulions politique au canada on
n'est pas du tout dans le pluralisme et
la polarisation on est dans le coup sans
se soustraient canadiens comme façon de
faire est historiquement avec aussi deux
peuples fondateurs qui doivent
travailler tout habité ensemble ça l'a
un peu seul édifice est donc
historiquement les partis politiques
étaient relativement similaires et pas
grand-chose qui disparaît à gouvernement
libéral de gouvernement conservateur on
a le centre gauche au centre droit et on
arrivait à trouver des consensus
mais dernièrement on voit une
polarisation au canada parce qu'on
commence emprunter des idées américaines
distillent américain est aussi et on les
confie son opposition en disant non non
non on a raison et on veut moins faire
de compromis qui ont une fois dans cette
campagne électorale
mais on vient juste de ya pas tellement
longtemps d'avoir un gouvernement
conservateur avant on avait des
gouvernements progressistes
conservateurs yen sapait les différences
entre ce que faisait notre journée
jusqu'aux fesses niveau n'a pas
effectivement c'est un peu le mot points
quand j'y consens droit vers une
politisation le gouvernement
conservateur actuel est plus à droite et
la population canadienne une porte
population canadienne le tirer vers la
droite on sait que c'est un parti qui
était divisé il ya à peu près une
vingtaine d'années que tu seras pas dire
mais en se remettant un peu plus vers la
droite de l'échiquier politique
alors que monsieur trudeau ça a été son
fait d'armes en 2000 canis monsieur
trudeau emmené le parti libéral plus à
gauche donc ce fameux milieu consensuel
qu'on voyait avec brian mulroney ou même
jean chrétien car il était libérale qui
est un petit peu plus de 130 re droit
n'est plus là on voit vraiment de peau
et on le voit pas juste sur la scène
fédérale mais on le voit dans plusieurs
provinces où c'est l'ontario c'est le
cas le québec c'est le cas même
l'alberta où la gauche a quand même pris
un certain ascendant et donc c'est un
phénomène je voudrais nouveau passage et
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs l'élection
actuelle je pense va permettre de voir
si on continue dans cette voie là aussi
les canadiens veulent revenir à un
consensus
on va dépendre de leur choix j'avais
très intéressant à vérifier
effectivement il ya eu une influence
américaine au canada
lille et madame télé je voulais vous
demander les cette influence américaine
on la voit dans les publicités
à une époque au canada on ne voyait pas
de message aussi négatif et en ce moment
il ya des messages très négatif il faut
très attentif pour lire en bas la source
qu'il parti conservateur
on a l'impression que le parti
conservateur est entré d'utiliser des
techniques américaines et vous avez
raison et ça s'explique le parti
conservateur sa balle c'est dans l'ouest
canadien
on dit souvent l'alberta l'alberta peut
être un peu d'autres provinces au tour
où des gens qui habitent dans les autres
provinces et un petit tour politique
une influence et des neame américaine
dans ce coin de pays beaucoup plus qu'on
peut voir au québec ou même un auteur
cette influence américaine est beaucoup
moindre
alors les sciences américaine amène des
idées américaines aussi puisqu'on voit
maintenant c'est la publicité des tiers
partis ce qui n'existait pas à voir
alors maintenant groupes de pression
peut décider de dépenser en campagne
électorale pour appuyer un candidat ou
un non et c'est surtout ses publicités
là qui sont négatives
on les voit elles sont avec des fonds
noirs ils sont hyper l'adversaire de
façon très chaude
oui
oui effectivement et donc on a un peu
style maintenant s'il faut pas oublier
c'est que aux etats unis ils ont plus de
groupes de pression qui peuvent être
prépositionnés dans différents à
différents endroits sur le spectre
politique alors la gauche la droite le
centre
au canada on n'est pas rendu là on est
un petit pays on n'a pas les moyens
d'avoir beaucoup de groupes de pression
qui pourraient faire contrepoids à ce
que d'autres disent qu encore une fois
je vous rappelle on n'est pas dans la
culture de pluralité de polarisation
dont je parlais au début donc six
week-ends équipières professeur atelier
je veux pas briser le brillant consensus
était de ramener un peu dans la centre
gauche aujourd'hui d'accord je voudrais
parler de joe big thing qui est le chef
néo-démocrate donc parti qui
historiquement est toujours de centre
gauche et la question de la religion du
port des symboles religieux
c'est un dossier qui existe au québec on
sait qu'ils jouent un rôle également
nouveau brunswick notamment au niveau de
la quasi j'entends pas de soucis
particuliers d'abord des lecteurs au
canada anglais par rapport au fait qu'un
chef de parti politique qui pourrait
devenir un premier ministre qui ne
ressemble pas à l'eau aux oraux premier
ministre précédent
mais cette question de désir religieux
elle fait partie d'un réveil politique
en ce moment au niveau de la nation je
suis sûr que même s'il perdait les
élections de la médecine est en train de
changer les choses quelque part oui oui
certainement et je faisais qui fait une
bonne campagne on avait des
appréhensions avant la campagne
mais effectivement pour plusieurs lieux
des bois récemment au québec qui dure
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs la question
de la laïcité de l'état
un peu comme on voit on voit se
manifester en france
alors est ce que les employés d'état
peuvent avoir des signes religieux ont
dit ostentatoire et donc oui visiblement
monsieur singh
des signes religieux on voit clairement
quelle est sa religion et c'est une
nouveauté ça pour les québécois c'est la
première fois qu'on voit un chef de
parti manifester son appartenance
religieuse de cette façon là et
lorsqu'on commence à découvrir c'est que
son discours politique n'est pas traitée
par ses convictions religieuses c'est un
peu ça la crainte que plusieurs saisir
oui mais ne me posais pas vous idées
religieuses
il faut pas oublier aussi qu'au québec
et un contexte où la religion a été
complètement évacué des institutions
publiques dans les années 60 c'est ce
qu'on a appelé la fameuse révolution
tranquille et donc on appréhende un peu
un retour de la religion il monsieur qui
est en train de démontrer en ce moment
que ça peut être ça peut cohabiter et
c'est peut-être un peu la surprise cette
campagne là au québec de voir justement
le comportement de ceux ci qui est très
sympathique qui a fait une publicité où
il y aura le dessin turban d'ailleurs
pour montrer ses crocs ses cheveux qui
collaborent de façon très candide
alors effectivement chacun avec vous ça
pourrait être un changement qui pourrait
se faire durant cette campagne
électorale
maryse ne vous battez pas non vas-y
raymond moi ce que je vois où si
particulier c'est ce sont les millenius
et les enfants de délai 20 ans ou tour
je sais comme moi j'ai ma fille qui à 23
ans on fait ceci voilà bah sont eux qui
qui ont presque sa plus grosse cohorte
cette élection aussi et l'environnement
l'environnement est ce qu'ils iront
voter
ça c'est la grande question alors
demandé à madame tu es gay est-ce que
d'après vous ces jeunes
est ce que désire on va tester la grande
question c'est la grande question et
j'en parlais à mes étudiants justement
et le parti naturel pour les jeunes en
ce moment c'est là c'est le parti vert
qui est le parti de l'environnement
malheureusement la chef mon ami arrive
pas a rejoint ces jeunes là premièrement
elle est beaucoup plus âgée pu alors
c'est un discours d'un peu plus âgés
c'est à dire qu'il parle moi des
préoccupations des jeunes oui à votre
promettent la gratuité des frais de
scolarité mais elle arrive pas
si tu es un engagement plus actif
dynamique des jeunes comme monsieur
trudeau l'avait fait en 2015 c'est cela
le gros point d'interrogation pour moi
monsieur trudeau en 2015 avait raconté
une histoire qui plaisait aux jeunes il
se présentait en bras de chemise savait
très décontractée dans des forums
citoyens avaient pu micro parle à tout
le monde répond à toutes les questions
très candide et on le voit pas chez les
autres chefs de parti surtout chez
madame et et on a encore jusqu'à présent
entendu aucune histoire porteur d'espoir
qui pourrait notamment attirer les
jeunes j'ai malheureusement pas
l'impression que les jeunes vont être
aussi enthousiaste septième élection sic
qui vont ils n'ont été en 2015
à moins qu'il ya un changement important
à matière environ d'environnement on
sait par exemple qu'il regrettait
mühleberg fameuse jeunes figures de
l'environnement revenir à montréal la
semaine prochaine
est-ce que sur ça pourrait susciter un
mouvement l'appel chez les jeunes un
rassemblement qui ont ensuite envoyé le
message bas il faut aller voter puis la
question d'environnement est important
ça va peut-être se produiront ya encore
30 jours pour la campagne mais on ne
voit pas encore puis c'est ça qui est
peut-être un peu inquiétant où les
jeunes sont les plus nombreux par contre
ce sont eux qui vote le moins encore
malheureusement et donc il faudrait
qu'ils participent plus activement comme
dans un excellent merci de laisser sur
cette question en suspens j'ai
l'habitude vous du 10 mai pisani a coûté
bon face aux ateliers ça fait plaisir de
vous découvrir personnage vous étiez
déjà connu régionalement celle est
apparu a créé deux occasions assez
nombreuses à la télé alors merci
philippe crise est partagée merci
beaucoup pour la mutation même démarre
alors dernière tellier de l'école
d'études politiques université d'ottawa
experte un comportement électoral
c'est vraiment intéressant et peut
espérer beaucoup moins beaucoup aimé
chez elle cette facilité d'expliquer à
des gens qui connaîtraient pas le canada
ce que c'est alain sa façon de faire des
références trop seul
rien merci merci bon dieu les phoques
soit catholique là parce que pendant ces
élections bientôt ma droite mais écoutez
je ne dira mot quand même j'étais
jésus-christ jeu voir s'ils voient
quelque chose va se produire d'accord
par action j'appréhende et voilà alors
non on a 30 bull à perdre vous avez
conservé vos vingt premières boules de
marteler ses boules
oui quelque chose me dit que quelqu'un
va faillir un peu comme moi comme je
suis réveillé j'ai choisi à croire aimer
quelqu'un en tête déjà ok alors voici
les amis on présente ça à l'écran pour
que tout le monde s'amuse
voilà pourquoi le parti élu le 21
octobre prochain pourra dire merci au
millénaire you est ce que c'est parce
que a
il voit plus que les autres canadiens
est ce que c'est parce que b il forme la
plus importante portion de l'électorat
canadien ou est ce que c'est c'est
attention là aucune de ces réponses et
je lui ai dit on y réfléchit alors ce
serait il forme la plus importante
portion de lectorat des points c'est des
jeunes de 18 à 38 ans à ça c'est notre
définition aujourd'hui il me savary a
selon les médias bon mais selon
élections canada 18 à 38 ans parfait
alors mme j b b à la grève demain des
césars man ray ban mais on vient d'en
parler nous et cela dit les nôtres loupe
est dans votre question
à c c'est aucune de ces réponses très
bien bah oui c'est bien moi je vais
aller avec marie-claude et je suis
d'accord avec son entente parce que
s'ils vont voter oui ça pourrait changer
des choses mais s'ils ne votent pas
certains voudraient aussi changer des
choses donc je vais avec des bébés alors
c'est qui a b alors y en a deux qui
tombe un peu par ces messieurs bonne
réponse on regarde ça ensemble
elle a de qui tenir
c'est toi et moi peut-être que j'ai un
manque quelque chose peste une fausse
rumeur de l'extrait bénac à la plus
importante fort sur le lecteur à
barreaux oui mais ça fait sacrément
avait dit là mais comme dit les faits
mais il sauf que je me suis fait avoir
ils pas parce que tu es et tu vois comme
une trame quelque chose d'une subtilité
l'intense parce qu'il me voit il connaît
il m'a vu venir plusieurs fois non on
vous connaît sa peine alors je vous
donne la réponse 10 millions ils sont 10
millions - sur les 27 millions
d'électeurs potentiels alors qu'ils
avaient tous voté in quiet plus du
soutien le dit tiens c'est incroyable ça
c'est juste ça s'est jamais vu parce
qu'avant c'était encore trop jeunes
beaucoup d'entre eux il faudra voir
s'ils font la file avec leur cellulaire
pour attendre de rentrer pour pouvoir
aller battait salle et un civil à ses
pratiquants ont fait la file moi je veux
ça fait seulement une couple d'années
que j'ai un cellulaire intelligent
avantage avec choses stupides mais bien
les affaires et puis quand j'atteins le
jeu mais très inquiète pour le genre
trempe
qu'est ce qu'il a dit or encore quelque
chose de brillant et voilà c'est comme
ça que je trouve ça me fait passer le
temps alors écoutez est-ce pas fini
notre émission je vous présenter ce que
j'appelle la poste entrevue j'offre
toujours le service après vente vous
savez sur la page web de tintin canada
sienna aux comptes et les items sur la
page web alors voilà c'est à oui c'est
ce qu'on offre pour les gens qui veulent
s'informer un peu plus vous reconnaîtrez
certains articles que vous avez déjà
écrit récemment qu'elle vrai visage
justin trudeau les chefs de partis
dévoilent leurs slogans pour les
élections ensuite on descend on descend
des fils louis les chefs de partis dits
voile lors ce pays dans ce que je fais
élection enflammé par les signes du
réchauffement
à chaque scrutin fédéral je n'aurais pas
fait de la bad à bonn post synchro - non
non alors la fcf aveux des députés
francophones à ottawa c'est quoi ça la
communauté francophone et acadienne
quand le canada droit qu'aux fans avec
un s et acadiennes sans s pourquoi parce
qu'il ya une communauté acadienne il ya
plusieurs autres communautés
francophones partout au canada
je ferai pas un débat là-dessus parce
que sa forêt de l'an écoutez on est prêt
pour le dernier jeu juste faire le tour
pour voir qui a perdu d
aujourd'hui une seule personne bull est
quand même chaud il ya quand même de
l'espoir et montre que quand même
passion il va faire un retour boisé où
on affiche la question du troisième et
dernier jeu à cette émission 50 boules à
perdre voici à partir de quel âge au
canada peut-on être un travailleur de
scrutin on va embaucher 300 mille
travailleurs de scrutin rappelez vous on
est 30 6 millions canadiens et élections
canada vont embaucher 300 travailleurs
de scrutin pour les élections c'est
beaucoup de monde ça en général c'est
des personnes âgées
voici à passer pour nous mais langil a
tout à fait le cdu stéphane parent plus
aujourd'hui tout à fait plus vous vous
êtes brouillés et cher à partir de quel
âge au canada peut-on être un
travailleur de scrutin est ce que c'est
à 16 ans est ce que ces bébés 18 ans
est-ce que c'est ses 21 ans
ou est-ce que céder aucune de ces
réponses
c'est fou parce que la majorité
différente au canada selon les provinces
ouais mais je pense que le droit de vote
c'est cet uniforme à travers le pays le
sort différent
oui mais moi je dirais b b 18 ans moi
aussi des résultats je suis la tendance
alors on va tous couler un singe est
parti avait vraiment tous couler
ensemble parce que si que si vous devez
2 cuil vous a découlé aussi sa dernière
demeure solidaire on affiche la bonne
réponse qui va couler douce ou pas
personne
la bonne réponse et d'attentats moi je
sais pas chanter
voilà c'est dit j'ai changé je pouvais
travailler
absolument c'est dans le fond ça par
rapport à il ya deux autres conditions
ne l'est
mais les mois pour être candidat pour
pourrait être recruté le canadien faut
pas été incarcérés canadien par habitant
nom et avoir 18 ans qu'à voir cela pour
être recruté comme candidat non non non
non pour travailler ouais non encore la
démission prochaine
ok mais là c'est vraiment dit canadien
il a raison faut être citoyen canadien
dernière qu il ya une troisième
condition pour accueillir faut pas
travailler au gouvernement non vous
pourriez travailler voulait pas avoir de
casier judiciaire ni non plus je pense
qu'ils doivent à regarder quand même
sont sûrs mais non c'est pas une
condition préalable qui vous exclut
complètement de la série certainement
pas être bilingue non plus alors c'est
le bail partisans libéraux j'attends je
sois le vote aujourd'hui c'est vrai on
voit pas on veut pas ça comme habillé
habillé de rouge pour y aller tu prêt
trailer je pense qu'il doit avoir quand
même un conseil au niveau des ouais
pourquoi et enfin pas tant un rouge
d'autant roussel en un problème parce
que là ça couvre maintenant avec les six
parties où il ya plein de colère mais le
bonheur c'est un parti aussi dire
esclaves non non c'est une mauvaise
blague ce matin alors écoutez est ce que
vous êtes prêt pour mon image de la
semaine m j'ai pas dis l'image la
semaine parce que l'image c'est le sait
ça c'est du justin trudeau
je suis une couleur différente
maintenant mon image de la semaine il va
falloir deviné je réponds seulement par
oui ou par non et on recommence est ce
que ces canadiens
oui tout à fait canal est ce que ça se
passe au canada seulement au canada
seulement
est ce que ces francophones ou
anglophones francophones
est-ce que c'est minérale ou végétale je
dirais minérale est ce que ça marche sur
deux pattes
oui
mais les rênes personne qui est proche
de nous c'est que peuvent probablement
quelqu'un vous avez déjà rencontré dans
la rue vous connaissez pas mais il ya de
bonnes chances que vous l'ayez rencontre
à montréal
oui à dallas maison de radio-canada et
ça concerne l'objet minérale a à
connaître qu'ils manipulaient un objet
minérale un objet ça fait la manchette
socialement pas tout à fait mais le
savez vous êtes dans le mode homme oui
tu fasses à la mine stirling moss - non
non minéraux a tenu en dépit d'actes et
d'écouter ça dépend des fois c'est du
zinc des fois c'est c'est celle
aluminium c'est fait c'est fait à quoi
une pièce de monnaie alors faites vous
iriez pièces de monnaie humble citoyen
banque laurentienne
oh oui le fameux monsieur kita les
présentait la vo 40 yens parce qu'il
avait accumulés à peu près 800 dollars
en pièces de monnaie et à la banque
laurentienne on lui a dit vous ne pouvez
pas on ne prend pas la monnaie ll était
outré donc prendre le maquis lire
ailleurs il a dû lutter pendant une
année c'est ce qui fait à chaque année
ensuite va à la banque laurentienne on
lui donne des dollars c'est ce que la
banque eut dit on prend plus le on prend
plus l'argent sonnant se finisse on
encourage plutôt les dépôts giteau
numérique comme ça aujourd'hui la savane
était bien organisé moi je suis un
client de la banque laurentienne
si je peux dévoiler sa en ondes et j'ai
déjà y'a pas si longtemps que ça j'ai
apporté mes mais disons qu'il ya
quelques années ça ça doit être vraiment
quelque chose de
nouvelle politique ils ont un petit peu
difficultés financières il faut
peut-être pas autant d'argent que les
550 grandes banques canadiennes
je pensais seulement 46 millions de
profits l'an dernier c'était alors ils
ont décidé de couper dans les services
et dans l'est le personnel et ils
peuvent plus manipuler l'argent et donc
du coup monsieur aller vers une de ces
machines ça coûte cher la sphère 12 % de
votre exactement qui ont annoncé julien
perrotte ai dit je vais perdre 100
dollars sur les huit centres
je veux changer de pas simplement oui je
suis pas su mieux encore des banques
acceptent l'argent sonnant laissé seul
dans le train de vivre une période
encore de transition toujours des
périodes de transition c'est fou je veux
qu'on va arriver à destination
alors voilà c'est tout pour cette
semaine j'avais pas du tout couvrir
merci ben moi je regarde je n'ai pas
grand chose à faire c'est fou ce qu'on
apprend des choses regardant nos amis
anglais en lisant mais se rappelle tous
c'est l'histoire de ces deux dames qui
ont chacune un pied d'une grandeur 9 et
alors imaginez exactement alors là
imaginez vous avez deux pieds de
différentes grandeurs
vous devez acheter tout vous tuiez en
double et la silice approuvé une
consoeur dans une autre province qui a
le même problème
alors ils vont s'échanger les souni qui
sont la mauvaise pointure pour pouvoir
nager c'est fini moi je trouve ça super
sympathique on devrait lancer un site
web juste pour les échanges de morceaux
de linge comme sol un
je mange trop court pour une personne va
à l'autre personne n'applique mans c'est
magnifique m bon écoute et là je voulais
pas vous quitter sans donner la parole à
marie claude simard
marie-claude notre patron s'est tassée
avec nous il ya je pense du jour voit
pas souvent et il
il partit en europe le huawei une
conférence importante des
radiodiffuseurs internationaux qui
s'occupe des liaisons courtes comme nous
ils étaient parsemés en ce moment il
nous a laissé un message il parlait donc
de notre nouvelle application de radio
canada international et ça fonctionne
extrêmement fort et c'est dommage qu'on
en parle pour plus c'est un succès c'est
pas comme c'est quelque chose tout à
fait alors d'abord moi je laisse mon
téléphone je pense qu'on le tout sur
notre téléphone l'application
radio canada international sàrl être
contenu encore plus beau qu'il naisse et
c'est possible alors voilà vous pouvez
le télécharger tout simplement sur votre
appareil en allant soit sur google et ou
pour les iphone
et puis vous pouvez le tenir dans cinq
langues new land qui sont le français
l'anglais l'espagnol et l'arabe et le
chinois tout à fait un mandarin mandat
vous et quand on aime en dollars on vous
encourage au dessus des gradins de télé
cher c'est quoi ces dix-neuf personnes
par jour nouvelle qui téléchargent qui
ajoute soi même un français je crois que
c'est plus simple à sa dépense a fait ça
fluctue un peu mais sont sincèrement en
grandissant dépendant de la langue
jamais vu apparemment c'est du jamais vu
oui alors vous irez vous hâtez vous dire
vous allez sur le percement et vous
lisez lorsque vous attendez avant des
baraques marie claude est encore avec
nous ou si bien le faire travailler un
peu un serment en profiter non mais oui
voici on a une autre vidéo pâton a
demandé ce qu'on présente alors ça
s'appelle là c'est sûr on va regarder
sens vous avez dû l'écrire comme c'est
un match de hockey de broyeurs tour
d'accord on regarde notre site web
oui c'est bien ça commence bien qu'est
ce qu'on fait ce site web
alors ça c'est notre page d'accueil ok
donc il est quoi plusieurs choses à
découvrir qu est-ce qu on peut voir
regarder vous pouvez vous abonner à note
c'est un magazine ou à notre les balados
exactement comme qui a été toute la
plateforme ans et une refonte complète
alors c'est très convivial et puis vous
pouvez écouter nos entrevues nounou
reportage où il ya douze you c'est très
facile aussi
d'y accéder très intéressant alors
j'imagine que vous avez quelque chose à
dire ghana joue non moi je pense c'est à
vous d'ajouter la suite et la fin à
cette émission pour nous annoncer une
grande nouvelle
grande nouvelle bon ok bah oui c'est
vrai oui oui ben écoute ont notamment eu
de plaisir je m'envole vers d'autres
projets german d'analystes plus de
photos plus de vidéos mais je pense que
j'en vends l'occasion de faire du
facebook live
alors ça va me manquer parce que c'est
vraiment une équipe en 2000 derrière la
prenais des choses c'est alors ton père
de bigpoint on apprenait nous et on
avait des boules un plus sur des boules
un mois ça fait combien de temps vous
perdez vos boules mais ça fait deux ans
et demi que j'ai je me suis joint à 25
et puis on peut dire que notre émission
a évolué ses formes
récompensé de transition encore une
nouvelle qui merci beaucoup à tout
l'équipe technique qui nous soutiennent
la pierre qui était un grand partisan
derrière tout ce que vous voyez à
l'écran en ce moment alors alors
nous remercions oui officiellement de
tous car marc andré deschamps benoît
durand et pire dit il n'y a pas de
caméra régime c'est sa venue à sa voix
dabbagh
on en voit terminer sur les images de
marie claude qui vint moi je vous dit au
revoir à tout le monde dira que vous à
l'écran que vous allez avant tout le
monde
alors revenez quand même toutes les
semaines revenu quand même toutes les
semaines sur facebook pour regarder
tam-tam canada on vous attend on aime
vous parlez on ne me parlait de notre
pays de nos politiques de nogent et puis
voilà l'équipe continue ça va bien aller
depuis nice et sa merci
[Musique]